To build a great gaming community,
you might also want to involve your
players in the game creation process.
>> Yeah, for our ball game I'm kind
of stuck on ways to improve it.
I can only get so
far by adding more rings of fire.
Where else do you think I should do?
>> Well, you could add multiple
balls of different sizes, and
I'm kind of getting tired
of the rings of fire.
What about including different obstacles
like maybe walls that you want to avoid?
>> Those are great ideas,
thanks for your feedback.
>> I'm happy to help.
>> None of us knows how to
build the perfect game.
But by listening to our players and
getting their feedback, you can
improve your game, and your players
will know that their input is valued.
So what are some ways that we can
include feedback in the game app?
>> There a couple of meaningful
ways to get feedback.
Most apps just use reviews and
ratings, but
you could also add in-app
messaging systems.
Surveys, forums and
whatever else you want to get to
increase player participation.
Recently, game developers
are actually inviting
fans to watch them on Twitch
as they're building the game.
This is really cool because developers
can get real time feedback from
potential players.
>> One great example of a strong gaming
and player community is the one for
League of Legends.
League of Legends gets feedback from
players from direct messages and
from forums.
The game has great graphics and has
a number of strong social components.
Players can chat with one another,
teams compete.
And there are even tournaments
watched throughout the world between
the strongest players.
And with such involved players,
this game makes a lot of money
off of in-app purchases that let players
personalize their experience and
enhance their gameplay.
Lots of players get so
involved that they even create
fan art based off of the game.